[Musique]
chaque année environ 21000 militaires
sont déployés en opération extérieure et
13000 assurent en permanence la
protection du territoire national et des
Français
pendant ce temps-là les familles
affrontent le quotidien sans le père ou
la mère elles attendent avec
enthousiasme ou anxiété un appel un
message une nouvelle
à ses absences souvent trop nombreuses
s'ajoutent aussi les mutations qui
bouleverse le foyer
pour compenser ses contraintes le
ministère des armées a lancé en 2017 un
plan d'accompagnement des familles et
d'amélioration des conditions de vie des
militaires doté d'une enveloppe de près
de 530 millions d'euros sur la durée de
la loi de programmation militaire
2019-2025
[Musique]
des actions attendues nécessaires car le
soldat a toujours vécu avec son temps
aujourd'hui pour lui s'accomplir ce
n'est pas seulement réussir sa vie
professionnelle c'est aussi préserver sa
vie familiale alors comment parents et
enfants sont-ils désormais soutenus
quelle est leur perception de ces
mesures et comment les familles
gèrent-elles cette vie atypique parfois
mal comprise par l'entourage
le journal de la défense vous propose
d'aller à la rencontre de celles et ceux
qui partagent la vie de militaires une
plongée inédite dans l'intimité de ceux
qui portent l'uniforme
[Musique]
dans son appartement à quelques pas de
l'arsenal de Toulon Jennifer compte les
heures la jeune femme de 26 ans enfant
de 6 mois et demi se prépare à retrouver
son conjoint second maître sur la
frégate entière Jean Bart
on va se retrouver et puis discuter de
ces quatre mois d'absence parce que mine
de rien il s'est passé des choses pour
lui comme pour moi donc ça va être un
grand moment de discussion et de
retrouvailles et puis l'occasion de voir
un peu des vidéos de son bébé bah du
coup qu'il n'a pas vu
à quelques minutes à bord du jean Bart
l'impatience se fait aussi sentir
[Musique]
les deux sont trompes marins du bâtiment
effectuent les dernières manœuvres avant
de rejoindre leur port d'attache à
Toulon
à qui l'accueil se met progressivement
en place sous un doux soleil hivernal
drapeau pour le bureau de liaison des
familles c'est le moment d'échanger avec
les proches des marins embarqués
de Toulon est un bureau chargé de faire
la liaison entre les familles et le
marin sur son bateau pendant que j'étais
en mer
on répond à des questions concernant la
vie à bord mais également des questions
d'urgence concernant les
hospitalisations les décès pendant que
le Marais est absent
ce bureau constitué de quatre marins a
été renforcé l'an dernier par 5
conjoints de militaires et services
ont une plus-value dans le sens où elles
savent ce que c'est que d'être conjointe
de marin en mer et pour les familles
c'est peut-être plus simple de
s'adresser à quelqu'un qui n'est pas en
uniforme et ça fait moins institutionnel
donc elles savent ce que c'est elles
comprennent mieux elles peuvent nous
faire remonter vraiment ce que
ressentent les familles à ce niveau-là
avec un contrat de 149 jours de réserve
par an elle est très souvent sollicitée
et vraiment d'apporter un soutien
concret aux familles de leur apporter
les informations au plus près du foyer
puisque on s'aperçoit très très souvent
que celle-ci ont du mal à quitter le
bateau pour arriver jusqu'à la maison
et créer aussi un lien entre les
familles une communauté en fait c'est un
peu à l'ancienne ou comme ça peut se
voir encore dans certains endroits que
les familles apprennent à se connaissent
et à se souvenir ensemble à vivre les
événements ensemble
au cœur des attentes les mesures qui
facilitent le quotidien
aux animaux une page Facebook sur
laquelle nous présentons les mesures du
plan famille une par une on les décline
et on l'explique et on répond aux
questions éventuelles s'il y a un doute
ou un problème de compréhension sur
certaines mesures
très attendu ce plan d'accompagnement
des familles et d'amélioration des
conditions de vie des militaires du plan
famille a été lancé en 2017 par la
ministre des Armées Florence Parly une
réponse un cri d'alarme
cette année-là selon le Haut comité
d'évaluation de la condition militaire
55% des militaires estimés que la
difficulté à concilier vie privée et vie
professionnelle était le principal frein
à l'engagement on recrute un soldat
mais c'est une famille entière qui
s'engage
et le souci porté aux familles bien sûr
n'est pas nouveau
mais il était nécessaire
d'y porter un regard ambitieux et
moderne
[Musique]
alors pour répondre aux attentes des
familles la direction des ressources
humaines du ministère a choisi de mettre
en place 48 actions et le Conseil
supérieur de la fonction militaire a
fait partie des organismes consultés
créés il y a 50 ans cet instance
nationale de concertation reconnue
assure le dialogue entre le ministre des
Armées son administration et les
militaires sa voix porte et a été
écoutée notamment lors de l'élaboration
de ce plan évolutif
moi je suis rentré dans la dans les
armées il y a un peu plus de 25 ans à
l'époque on nous disait la famine ne
fait pas partie du sac c'est ce qu'on
entendait avant et effectivement
maintenant on peut pas dire que la
famille ne fait ne fait pas partie du
sac on a obligé de prendre en compte en
fait quand un soldat s'engage que soit
une femme ou un homme il faut prendre en
compte le conjoint qui va subir nos
suggestions nos absences du fait de
notre statut militaire si on part en
mission et qu'on sait que la base
arrière est suivie ou aidé ou c'est un
petit peu plus facile pour le moral de
la troupe donc les mesures qui ont été
prises dedans c'est surtout tout ce qui
concernait l'accompagnement du conjoint
l'accompagnement des enfants la garde
etc qui était important pour nous
en effet l'absence d'un conjoint affecte
l'organisation de la vie courante
notamment la garde des enfants qui est
l'une des principales sources
d'inquiétude
l'augmentation du nombre de places en
crèche et donc une priorité pour les
parents
c'est le cas à Pamiers dans l'Ariège ou
une micro crèche de 10 berceaux
administré par l'institution de gestion
sociale des armées a été inauguré à la
fin de l'été
une belle opportunité pour le premier
régiment de Chasseurs Parachutistes
situé à proximité
il faut savoir que le régiment c'est
plus de 1000 personnes c'est une
naissance par semaine donc un besoin
assez important et que la particularité
du première CP c'est une des
particularités des premières CP c'est
d'être un régiment qui est localisé dans
une zone plutôt rurale on est plutôt à
la campagne on a pas exactement dans le
centre de Pamiers on est un peu à
l'extérieur de la ville de Pamiers pour
6 km environ du centre-ville et donc
cette crèche située juste à côté du
régiment représente un intérêt dans
l'organisation puisque ça permet aux
cadres et parachutiste de régiment de
déposer leurs enfants en venant au
régiment
les horaires de la crèche ont été
adaptés afin de pouvoir accueillir les
enfants un peu plus tôt que les crèches
municipales alentours et les garder un
peu plus tard le soir
la structure possède une autre
particularité 4 des 5 salariés sont des
conjointes de militaires
au niveau de la création des emplois
c'est important
voilà de penser aussi au conjoint de
militaires ce qui est bien avec les GESA
c'est que elles peuvent continuer à
travailler en crèche dans une autre
région elles peuvent être mutées si le
conjoint est muté donc elles peuvent
rester au sein de l' IGESA peu importe
où elles vont ce qui est important aussi
c'est le regard aussi qu'elles peuvent
apporter à la crèche elles ont le regard
professionnel et aussi personnelles deux
personnes pour toi
avant je travaillais en maternité donc
les horaires sont assez compliqués au
niveau de la vie de famille et des
horaires de mon mari qui au premier CP
et donc voilà en étant à côté j'ai
beaucoup moins de route que mon ancien
emploi et puis c'est un métier que
j'aime beaucoup donc voilà j'ai pas
hésité à postuler en plus c'est un CDI
donc voilà beaucoup de choses positives
un sentiment partagé par les premiers
bénéficiaires de ces places
c'est une amie qui m'a conseillé de
venir ici du coup je suis venue et
franchement nickel lui ça lui plaît
carrément il est bien épanoui
je vois tous les jours qu'il a qu'il
évolue de plus en plus alors que ça fait
deux mois qu'il est là mais là déjà
beaucoup beaucoup évolué quoi c'est très
pratique que comme ça quand je les
récupère après on récupère papa et on
rentre à la maison un trajet en un on
fait tout en même temps
pour le papa de la petite Jade première
classe au sein du régime cette crèche
est le signe que la prise en compte des
familles s'améliore ça fait du bien en
ce sens soutenu et du coup on permet de
ça nous permet de devoir plus loin dans
nos projets familiaux et personnel et
puis aussi ça permet d'être un peu plus
on va dire décontracté pour se dire ok
on peut évoluer professionnellement on
sait que ça suit derrière
on bientôt
l'objectif est d'augmenter de 20% le
nombre de places d'ici 2022 des places
qui peuvent aussi bénéficier aux agents
civiles du ministère car si certaines
mesures sont liées à l'état de militaire
60% des actions du plan peuvent
s'appliquer au personnel qui ne portent
pas l'uniforme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur la base de défense de Nancy la garde
d'enfants est aussi au cœur des
préoccupations une nouvelle structure en
expérimentation la cellule d'information
et d'accompagnement des familles a été
créé pour prendre en compte ces
problématiques
[Musique]
bon sinon ça va oui
on a pu trouver finalement comme je vous
avais dit ça se passe bien
ce jour là la djudant-chef Sébastien
fait le point avec un jeune
sous-officier du service des essences
des armées et s'accompagne récemment
arrivée dans la région il m'a donné une
liste d'assistante maternelle que j'ai
dû contacter en fonction de mon adresse
donc j'ai ciblé des assistantes qui
étaient vraiment proches du domicile car
comme je vous dis si je travaille loin
ou si lui il ne peut passer déplacer au
moins c'est plus facile pour nous
d'aller le récupérer ou de le déposer
franchement pour moi tant que femme de
militaire j'estime que c'est une très
bonne cellule car on arrive dans une
nouvelle vie déjà on doit s'adapter à la
ville en tant que jeune maman aussi on
doit s'adapter à notre nouvelle vie et
du coup ça permet d'être en confiance
dans la vie qu'on va mener ça nous aide
à avoir de nous de développer des
éléments savoir où aller dans la ville
si par exemple on veut faire du sport
connaître des associations
ça nous donne tous les éléments et
certaines AD resses à connaître dans la
ville
cette cellule a pour mission de soutenir
les unités et formations isolées et la
tâche n'est pas mince ici dans cette
garnison cela représente pas moins de
1350 familles un accompagnement au long
cours qui se fait dès la reconnaissance
d'affectation du militaire jusqu'à son
départ en opération extérieure et qui
prend plusieurs formes on organise aussi
des informations
avec différents organismes associations
extérieures comme la CAF donc la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales on a fait venir
la CPAM donc la caisse primaire
assurance maladie la DEAL donc qui est
l'association d'informations et
logements voilà donc on essaie
d'organiser différentes informations
afin que
la personne qui vient d'arriver dans
dans notre base de défense ne soit pas
perdu et l'un des atouts majeurs de
cette cellule c'est son positionnement
l'avantage de ce bâtiment c'est que on
appelle ça le bâtiment Paul famille car
il rassemble le bureau logement la
Défense Mobilité et les attentes
sociales ce qui permet aux nouveaux
arrivants de d'avoir tous les bureaux
sur place ici c'est le bureau logement
bonjour Laurence j'ai eu un appel ce
matin d'une famille qui recherche un
logement
une famille avec deux enfants donc je me
suis permise de tes coordonnées au
contact dans l'après-midi
d'accord une colocation qui a déjà porté
ses fruits
nous avons des résultats très précis
nous allons plus d'une cinquantaine de
familles qui viennent chaque mois à la
formation et de la colleplant
d'accompagnement des familles nous avons
pour l'emploi du conjoint par exemple
Défense Mobilité qui a multiplié par
deux le nombre de dossiers pour
accompagner des conjoints sur Nancy et
par trois sur la base de défense en un
an de même les assistants sociales
voient plus d'accès le bureau logement à
un meilleur aiguillage mais pour le
commandant de base ce n'est que le début
alors les prochaines étapes c'est
d'abord le maintien le maintien de cette
dynamique parce que le travail de
reconquête des familles d'accompagnement
des familles est un travail de long
terme l'emploi opérationnel est
important la base de défense de Nancy
pour ses unités opérationnelles et à
vocation expéditionnelle et donc toutes
les unités sont extrêmement projetées
donc les familles sont en demande de
soutien de manière cyclique et régulière
en Charente-Maritime nous retrouvons
Aurélie à 41 ans cette femme de
militaire vient tout juste de retrouver
un emploi d'assistante administrative au
centre médical des armées de la base
aérienne de Rochefort gérons donc de la
simple permission à l'arrêt de travail à
la demande de congé maternité un dossier
contentieux les notations on gère
vraiment tout de A à Z parce qu'on fait
la RH la solde et la Chancellerie
[Musique]
après avoir travaillé 17 ans dans
l'armée est connu quelques soucis de
santé cette mère de famille a cherché
pendant plusieurs années apprendre un
nouveau départ dans des domaines aussi
variés que l'événementiel la
restauration ou l'aide à la personne
mais aucun deux n'a abouti à une
situation stable et c'est une discussion
avec son mari qui lui a permis de tenter
une nouvelle approche en fait un soir il
est rentré et après mes démarches et mes
multiples
CV que j'ai pu faire dans tous les
organismes avec des réponses soit
négatives ou pas du tout de réponse donc
j'étais quand même désormais et un soir
il m'a expliqué que sur la base il y
avait la Défense Mobilité qui était donc
déconseillé qui était là pour nous qui
représentait Pôle emploi qui faisait
même des marches mais plus approfondi et
que à travers ça comme moi j'étais
conjointe de militaire j'avais le droit
à des possibilités beaucoup plus
importantes
spécialiste des systèmes d'information
et de communication depuis 10 ans dans
l'armée de l'air le sergent chef Ludwig
et lui aussi en pleine période de
transition j'ai été bien accompagné par
Défense Mobilité quand j'ai eu la fin de
mon contrat approché
et les personnes de Rochefort ont comme
le disait enfin ils prennent à cœur les
personnes qui suivent et m'ont dit mais
il me voyait inquiet parce que ma femme
ne trouvait pas d'emploi dans la région
sa société était tombée à l'eau donc les
inquiétudes arrivent on a les charges
tous les jours la vie courante on a une
famille donc je commençais vraiment à
m'inquiéter ils m'ont dit mais fais
venir ta femme il y a le plan famille
elle sera conseillée et suivie comme toi
tu l'as été
une nécessité afin que chacun puisse
retrouver son autonomie
pour le moment tu sais que maman elle
adore le café une famille est en couple
c'est surtout avoir un ensemble que ce
soit l'amour même le travail enfin c'est
un équilibre de vie et on avait besoin
de ça
c'est ainsi qu'après 5 mois de coaching
aurélie a pu décrocher un CDD auprès du
service de santé des armées
elle a rendez-vous pour faire un bilan
avec Sophie sa conseillère Défense
Mobilité je l'accompagnais dans tout ce
qui était technique de recherche
d'emploi on a revu son CV ensemble je
l'ai incité à démarcher auprès de tes
agences d'intérim se faire connaître
développer son réseau je l'ai poussé je
l'ai accompagné maintenant si elle
n'avait pas été active je sais pas si
aujourd'hui on en serait là si tout va
cet accompagnement personnalisé n'aurait
pas été possible il y a quelques années
encore une convention avec Pôle emploi
qui a été passée avec cette convention
en fait les conjoints peuvent être
suivis par Défense Mobilité ou par Pôle
Emploi donc voilà ce qui ce qui a changé
en fait c'est qu'aujourd'hui on peut les
suivre de A à Z on peut monter un
dossier de financement dans le cas d'un
plan famille pour un conjoint qui
souhaite faire une formation
voilà et des forces mobilité à une
enveloppe budgétaire pour former les
conjoints à hauteur de 6000 euros et ce
suivi peut se poursuivre encore trois
ans après que le militaire a quitté
l'armée en 2019 Défense Mobilité a ainsi
permis à 1500 conjoints de trouver un
emploi donc 40% en CDI
partons maintenant en Bretagne à Brest
où nous avons rendez-vous avec Caroline
cette maman de deux enfants est bientôt
3 et marié à Benjamin un officier de la
marine nationale actuellement en mission
sur un bâtiment
on dit quoi
avec sa fille Louise 5 ans et demi elle
utilise le kit enfant imaginé par deux
épouses de militaires cette valisette
colorée remplie de cartes d'enveloppes
d'autocollants et même d'un calendrier
la fibre court à la créativité de chacun
son objectif aider les familles à garder
plus facilement le lien avec le conjoint
en mission et à mieux gérer son absence
autour d'une activité manuelle
[Applaudissements]
donc il y a des choses simples qui
existent mais c'est vrai que ce kit
apporte aussi de nouvelles solutions et
aussi quelque chose de tout prêt pour
les parents qui n'ont pas forcément soit
le temps soit les idées à mettre en
place à la maison on a regardé le
fonctionnement et on a choisi les choses
qui nous semblaient plus parlant pour
lui en l'occurrence on a choisi le
planning qu'on a commencé à compléter
avant le départ avec mon mari pour
mettre des dates clés dessus et des
Louis à se repérer dans le temps et on
l'a utilisé après de manière plus plus
espacées quand Louise ressentait le
besoin on n'a pas pour but fait de lui
montrer au quotidien l'absence mais
vraiment on l'utilise quand elle ressent
le besoin de faire un point sur
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce qui
reste encore à venir et quand est-ce que
papa rentre qu'est-ce que tu racontes
sur le planning
tu écris quoi
d'accord par exemple qu'est-ce qu'on a
pu écrire là sur le planning
école vacances
yoga
musique
papy et mamie
donc ça c'est pour raconter un petit peu
quand papa il va rentrer que tu lui
racontes ce que tu as pu faire et ben
[Musique]
soit et pyjamas
et parfois qu'est-ce que tu mets là par
exemple
des gommettes pour l'école
pique
des chaussures de sport le kit a été
conçu comme une boîte à outils que
chaque famille peut s'approprier en
complément de ses propres petits rituels
on a la classe qui nous permet aussi de
suivre en fonction des escales le
parcours de papa et de montrer aux
enfants où est-ce qu'il est par rapport
à nous est-ce que c'est loin est-ce que
c'est proche est-ce qu'il est sur le
retour ou plutôt sur le départ après
il y a pas il y a pas de choses
prédéfinies on s'adapte vraiment en fait
d'une mission à l'autre avec aussi les
enfants qui grandissent et les besoins
qui qui changent donc pour l'instant ça
reste ça avec des là on a la chance
d'avoir aussi des contacts en direct par
téléphone lors des escales qui font du
bien aux enfants mais c'est vrai que on
a eu des patrouilles en sous-marin où là
on est obligé effectivement de trouver
d'autres solutions parce que pour le
coup il n'y a pas du tout de contact
pendant la pendant la patrouille et pour
les enfants
c'est c'est important qu'ils arrivent à
avoir ce quand même ce maintien du
contact alors qu'il y a plus de contact
qui est assez compliqué quand papa est
pas là et qui te manque qu'est-ce que tu
fais de lui par exemple
m'a offert opération extérieure
manoeuvre exercice le militaire en
activité est souvent absent du foyer des
séparations difficiles auxquelles la
famille se prépare comme elle peut
alors c'est vrai que au tout début quand
on se marie on nous dit bah tu le savais
on entend souvent cette phrase tu le
savais il parait c'était prévu il allait
partir que tu serais souvent seul donc
on le sait on s'en doute mais tant qu'on
le vit pas on
l'appréhende pas en fait
au début c'est difficile parce que on
est en tant que couple du coup on est
vraiment deux personnes et quand la une
des personnes s'en va on se retrouve
seul généralement plus dans une ville où
on n'a pas forcément notre famille nos
proches donc on se retrouve isolé et
c'est pour ça aussi que le plan des
familles qui a été mis en place est
important ne serait-ce que par le fait
de pouvoir avoir cette mobilité SNCF en
permanence maintenant
et au fur et à mesure la vie se
construit les patrouilles se font et on
s'adapte par exemple donc quelques
semaines Louise pourra retrouver son
papa et lui montrer son calendrier
l'occasion pour elle de lui raconter
tout ce qu'elle a pu faire pendant leur
séparation depuis octobre 2018 20 milles
qui ont ainsi pu être distribués et une
deuxième version est à l'étude
[Musique]
retour à Toulon la tente touche à sa fin
pour Jenifer le Jean Bart est en train
d'accoster devant des familles qui ne
cachent plus leur excitation
pour la jeune femme impossible de
contenir son émotion
s les anniversaires manqués les gestion
de crise en solitaire laissent peu à peu
leur place au bonheur de se retrouver
tes instants suspendus intimes où il est
parfois compliqué de trouver les bons
mots de se réapprivoiser
[Musique]
de la grossesse que j'ai pas
malheureusement pas vécu mais bon en mer
pour pour l'accouchement donc c'est le
principal
[Rires]
[Musique]
les présences à des événements marquants
sont des souvenirs précieux des
victoires pour celui qui a l'habitude de
partir
car être en couple avec un militaire
ressemble parfois à une longue bataille
[Musique]
mais sur le front les familles sont
désormais plus soutenues
quittents place en crèche accompagnement
au retour à l'emploi ce ne sont que
quelques exemples des aides mis en place
des aides qui ne supprimeront pas les
contraintes de la vie militaire mais qui
épauleront davantage les proches de ceux
et celles qui s'engagent pour la France
[Musique]